allons soyez le ou la bienvenue à votre
tandem canada du 2 avril
ouf le 1er avril est passé peu plus de
poisson d'avril c'est fini ces histoires
autour de la table il y a cinq
animateurs je fais le tour d'abord il ya
stéphane parent yara dit baye de la
section française de radio-canada
c'est un bon jour je saute anne-marie
quelques secondes je redis il y as we ou
de la section chinoise et internationale
qui est avec nous leonardo gimeno notre
chef technicien du web qui nous
accompagnent de la section
latino-américaine bonjour elle marie je
reviens vous oui j'ose des femmes
bonjour on est content vous avoir avec
nous vous travaillez plus maintenant
avec radio canada international mais
vous travaillez pour le service espace
autochtone de radio canada
nos bureaux sont à 1-1 côté de l'otan
que vous êtes encore partis quand je ne
suis pas très loin jamais très loin mais
était très loin la semaine dernière et
si perdue d'un an vous aviez beaucoup de
plaisir
alors là c'est tellement drôle pas je
vous avais prévenu avant de partir je
partais pour man wan et le nord n'est
pas si loin que ça parce que 250 km de
montréal
on s'imagine que c'est loin mais ce
n'est pas loin la route peut être un peu
difficile parce qu'il ya un chemin
forestier de 86 km à suivre et lorsque
je les ai suivis à l'aller il était à la
fois glace et boueux cahoteux alors
c'était un petit peu long mais on retour
un peu plus sec
il n'y avait pas de glace semblait bien
vous êtes au courant du thème de
l'émission cette semaine on va parler
des transports et en sport tout le matin
ou dans le métro un qu'on soit au dessus
ou sous terre c'est la même chose c'est
l'embouteillage sait on sent que les
sardines
est-ce qu'il ya du transport en commun
dans votre dans cette belle région vous
avez visité du nord comment les vacances
oui on commence transporte en ski doo
eau et en voiture ils sont faites plus
en quatre par quatre à cause de cette
fameuse route parce que bon je vais vous
dire tout de suite je suis allé
rencontrer des professeurs africains qui
travaillent là bas et qui prennent
souvent la route justement pour rentrer
dans non pas dans leurs communautés ben
oui dans leur communauté d'origine donc
dans leur famille alors ils ne vivent
pas à manawan de façon permanente ils
ont un logement qui leur est fournie à
un prix modique et ils reviennent toutes
les deux ou trois semaines dans leur
famille dont qu'ils ont à faire cette
fameuse route
ce qui veut dire qu'elle
fin de l'année ça leur a coûté quelques
pare brise et quelques suspensions
ah oui c'est vrai l'ex trash de la qui
sortent en alberta on avait le même
problème lorsque j habitais et ses
camions c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
coupes de bois dans ce coin-là selon
qu'on croise des gros camions et
évidemment des fois ils nous envoient
quelques jets de pierre et voilà la
reprise pas de problème d'embouteillage
donc à manawan meilleurs au pays on sait
que c'est un problème notamment dans les
cinq grandes villes canadiennes voici ma
question première question tour de table
c'est le jeu-questionnaire numéro un de
la semaine que je gagne d'habitude peut
plus poser de question qu il ne faut pas
commencer par n ont pas tous la même
chose c'est vrai mais je peux pas
commencer par les eaux parce qu'il a la
réponse il prépare déjà la vidéo qui
accompagne d'accord alors vous a quelle
est selon vous la plus grande ville par
la plus grande ville mais la family 100
grandes villes canadiennes dont toronto
montréal ottawa vancouver il y en a
peut-être une autre amérique a dit
ribéry
parmi ces grands vilains quelle est
celle qui connaît le plus propre plus
grand problème d'embouteillage au
quotidien je crois que c'est trop tôt
oui je crois que c'est toronto ouais
mais honnêtement je n'ai j'ai conduit
une fois à toronto mais à la fin de
semaine
mais sauf que c'est quand même c'est
assez je pense que c'est casse tête pour
ceux qui m'aiment pour ceux qui
utilisent le transport en commun le
train de banlieue
ça prend beaucoup de temps oui tandis
qu'à vancouver aussi j'étais jeune j'ai
déjà visité sept fils et conduire là
aussi à une grosse embouteillages mais
j'ai l'impression que la ville est pile
est structurée comme avec thé et aux
rues quadrillées
samar al elle dû nord sud est et ouest
pendant qu'on est à la recherche de la
bonne réponse je vous le dis tout ceci
n'est pas la bonne réponse
les images qui ont été croquées sur le
vif c'est en accéléré par un
automobiliste de vancouver il ya très
peu de thym donc à la vitesse grand v
peut être cinq fois plus rapidement que
ce qu'il a vécu
l'embouteillage dans cette ville on
cherche le nom de la ville 32 canadienne
où les embouteillages sont les plus
importants au canada à n'arrivons
réponse vous avez l'image peut-être que
vous pouvez regarder peut-être des
indices dans cette image attendez que je
regarde bien fort et je vois la plaque
d'immatriculation ça m'aiderait beaucoup
moins 2 d'office je dirais montréal
parce que j'en ai tellement vécu des
embouteillages et surtout en ce moment
avec les travaux de construction de
remise à niveau de tout ce qu'on veut on
prépare aussi le 375e de la ville alors
je me dis c'est mort et un saignement
rien ça ressemble beaucoup à montréal ce
n'est pas la bonne réponse
razik avait toujours la réponse juste
quelle est cette réponse à vancouver
voilà vous ne l'aviez peut donner un
honnêtement j'allais dire toronto où
elle allait dire ton retour j'avais
l'impression sédition après que toronto
ils ont ils ont deux ils ont un tram du
coup ça je pense que je me suis dit que
peut-être ça ça réduisait les problèmes
de ça aide
voilà justement ils ont annoncé
d'ailleurs cette semaine lors du budget
de fédérale lors du dépôt le milliard
800 millions de dollars additionnels
pour le gauthrin le système de transport
pas vert mais rapide de ce rail à
vancouver alors calmes en rien le débat
se poursuit
elle attend toujours projette un petit
peu déraillé le soulier dans ces jeunes
et pourquoi pas à montréal justement
pourquoi espérons en a pas ici
s'ils voulaient on va garder cette
question en suspens récupérer non
seulement les bonnes réponses aux
questions mais les bonnes questions
voilà ça va alors je vais vous proposer
donc attendez c'est donc ouvertement que
le problème de circulation on va
comparer les choses dans la population
de toronto c'est vraiment un grand
succès c'est compliqué quand même
j'ai connu des gens qui est qui habitent
leur pied à mafate y travaillent à
toulon taux de 3 jours par semaine puis
ils vont pas en avion pascal un avion ça
signifie saint cyr de vers le
centre-ville puis c'est la folie il
prend beaucoup plus de temps
des personnes tuées voilà ça c'est quand
même c'est ccifci voici les statistiques
d'accord on joue au jeu des statistiques
deuxième jeu questionnaire de la semaine
sur 60 minutes de trajet type à
vancouver combien y ait deux minutes
notre automobiliste roule t-il en fait
au ralenti sur 60 minutes de combien de
ces mines et de passe-t-il au ralenti
avec vous tiennent lé au cours une fois
mobilis talents ouvert minutes assis
dans son auto
[Musique]
oui vous qui avez l'expérience qu'elle
était passée presque à moitié
j'avais juste passé 36 mail jean n'ira
même pas à roux a dit l'arrêté c'est
tellement 20 37 minutes à travers
pratique seulement pour n'est pas raison
sur 69 kong et notre to be still au
ralenti sur société les poches des
requins c'est tranquille autres
comparses ans était avec eux avec ton
tour tu aurais donc je dirais à montréal
au battrai donc ouvert oui c'est vrai
mais je dirais 25 à 35 dans tout ça
n'est plus élu le 27 mai a coûté 32 je
suis pas fier raison
entre les deux lionel roye ça s'est
amélioré un petit peu dit il
depuis qu'on fait les statistiques
depuis 5 1 11 % d'amélioration du temps
niveau du compass un peu moins d'un mois
yann on passe 87 heures derrière
survolant à rouler au ralenti par année
lorsqu'on était à vancouver
oui mais cette année le pourcentage
assez bon on a eu 10 heures dans la 13
avec la tempête
ces images il ya des gens qui ont passé
vraiment de fausser le tout c'est
salutaire personnages et puis personne
pour amasser les véhicules qui étaient
emprisonnés manège pour les sortir de là
voici ce que ça donne comme résultat ça
donne bien sûr des gens qui sont
attachés comme des sardines dans les
métros dans les transports en commun
parce qu'on veut éviter passer par la
route ou encore il yad'autres qui
s'entête à passer par la route et ça
donne des cas de rage au volant je passe
vous avez déjà vécu ça un petit épisode
personnel vidéo de monsieur qui a
poursuivi un famille qui est sensé avec
une chaîne commence à peine à se dresser
au nord de marjah
c'est finalement y'a pas eu
d'accusations ils l'ont l'essai allait
adopter cette mauvaise journée pour lui
tourner un film
alors voici justement une de ses vidéos
virales ça se passe à toronto parce
qu'on à toronto on dit que ça se passe
quand même mieux parce qu'en terme de
population et c'est tout un succès mais
quand même des fois il ya des ratés
voici une scène croqué par cbi si donc
la télévision française de et je je je
place la vidéo pour vous il ya un
policier une équipe de qui tourner des
images avec le policier pour parler des
circulations au dessus d'un viaduc et
tout d'un coup on attend des gros mots
au bas du viaduc et un embouteillage
deux automobilistes qui se regardent la
scène et montons un peu le son pour être
sûr d'atteindre ils se parlent en
anglais mais je pense que c'est un
langage universel
qu'est ce que l'on voit en ce moment là
de ses fils gigabit d'entre eux montent
alors là je pense qu'il nous manque le
son parlement qu'il nous sans lien
censure on sait que partout on travaille
à une censure jeudi on a vu l'anglais
attendez donc ces deux personnes qui
s'invectivent et le policier qui dit
aller les bons réseaux les allées c'est
fini la récréation là est un des
conducteurs qui dit elle a tué le
policier est là il me dit d'y aller d'y
aller
donc si ça calme quand même comme rage
rage au volant
oui oui si on pense que cette jeune
maman qui s'est fait casser de bras
[Musique]
mobilisant va si vite si elle n'avait
pas protégé sa tête avec ses deux mois
voulant réduire
j'étais déjà j'aimais pas si mal que ça
mais il ya un monsieur qui sans ses
parents voient aucun jeu gta iv il a
fait la loi merci
mais son antre de vendre les lumières et
sortir moi c'est ma voiture j'ai appelé
la police et puis quand j'ai montré que
je ne veux mais celui-ci a fait dire que
lâchés sur mon pied par dessus je fais
là
j'ai appelé la police jeudi je donne à
la plaque l'articulation puis le soir
même la police m'a appelé pour voir si
je voulais porter bien
il fallait à lester laval alger quoi
mais j'ai dit merci vous pouvez
téléphoner plaisir d éviter ce genre de
choses bien fait de pas faire sinon je
me serais retrouvé en cours non parce
que des fois ça arrive qu'on est de
l'autre côté un petit peu on est nerveux
même c'est rare très attendu tout je
reçois des coups de camions tous les
côtés j'avais posé la question pour vous
c'est que diddy qui conduisait longtemps
pourquoi place psychologie change tant
parce que j'ai eue là dessus ce parce
que les gens sont dans une bulle de
verre et donc ils sont un peu pris un
petit environnement qu ils sont
deviennent mono moi c'est l'explication
scientifique nécessaire parce qu'on voit
ici mais donne des convois lot de
personnes on voit ses 13 ans et qui sait
des fois des fois on se en 2d s'adoucir
est ce que c'est pour ça qu'on met les
petits collants bébé à bord à votre avis
dans l'est dans les véhicules juste pour
que la personne qui est derrière nous
pourquoi puisse se dire tiens dans cette
voiture là il ya un petit bébé je vais
quand même pas être trop trop méchante
avec mais dès qu'on l'enlève finalement
peut-être les gens après il je vous
conseille de le faire mais ça va faire
une liste mairie on va passer aux
transports en commun parce que c'est pas
une réalité que je vis depuis maintenant
six ans maintenant que je conduis tout
va bien mais dans le transport en commun
je voudrais pas passer ici en revue les
scénarios difficile que vous auriez vécu
mais avant pour ceux qui sont allés côte
dans le monde entier leur faire
comprendre à quoi ça ressemble des fois
les transports comme à montréal une
belle ville moderne un peu vis
vieillissante alors voici j'ai préparé
pour vous ça dure 3 minutes 30 secondes
patience c'est les explications et après
sa non témoignage personnel
on y vient
je vais dans une station de métro avec
une petite équipe ça s'appelle li ou
direct s'est annoncée dans le journal 24
heures et ça donne des résultats au delà
de nos espérances il ya prêté à 20
personnes qui viennent chaque semaine
pour pour nous rencontrer qui ont des
questions des commentaires et c'est très
utile d'avoir ce poules oies de la
clientèle directement dans le réseau ça
permet de réfléchir de façon plus
concrète à ce qu'on veut faire au cours
des dix prochaines années on est dans
cet exercice temps il faut rédiger le
plan stratégique que jusqu'à 2025
et pour ça on le fait avec la clientèle
on transporte des gens vous fait pas que
des places et des autobus et des
méthodes déjà à bas donc il faut que nos
idées soient en lien avec ce que la
clientèle souhaite on et entassés comme
des bêtes dans l'autobus c'est
insupportable en et entassés et je
prends l'autobus au deuxième arrêt après
le métro a donc imaginé un peu il ya
plusieurs personnes qui n'arrivent même
pas à le prendre et c'est quotidien ces
quotidiens c'est devenu insupportable et
c'est un facteur de stress énorme avant
d'aller arrivée au travail
on est toujours stressé est ce qu'on va
pouvoir prendre notre transport est ce
qu'on va pouvoir arriver à l'heure à
notre travail ça devient vraiment
surtout ces dernières années je vous
dirais les deux dernières années sans
particulièrement difficile au niveau de
l'autobus mais au métro si vous
remarquez si vous prenez votre auto de
votre métro c'est l'achalandage est
énorme la population s'accroît à
montréal et on dirait que le moyen de
transport ne suis pas ne s'adaptent pas
et sous terre des sardines prennent
aussi place
vous
pour remettre sur les rails le transport
en commun montréalais un méga projet du
jamais vu depuis la construction des
barrages géants du grand nord québécois
dans les années 70 sont donc sur les
planches à dessin les autorités la
caisse de dépôt et placement du québec
n'hésitez pas à parler en avril dernier
du projet le plus important des 50
dernières années en transport en commun
à montréal
il ira dans cinq ans premier temps 24
stations 67 km de rails de plus soit la
même longueur que l'actuel métro de
montréal 5,5 milliards de dollars un
système léger sur rail électrique
entièrement automatisée qui seront
intégrés au réseau transport existants
fonctionnent en 20 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7
au moins cent cinquante mille passagers
l'utilisera chaque jour la promesse est
énorme
selon nous c'est réaliste taxis est ce
que cette exigence
oui cet exigeant est-ce que c'est
ambitieux oui c'est ambitieux je pense
et faut être ambitieux et donc il faut
voir grand
maiko sebia pdg de la caisse de dépôt et
de placement du québec et je pense que
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
décidé de proposer ce projet parce que
nous avons une vision du développement
de montréal du développement du québec
et donc avec une tel système aux
technologies nous allons japon nous
avons pas juste la caisse mais mémorial
nous avons eu l'occasion devant nous de
transformer de transformer notre ville
et donc ça c'est évidemment c'est fait
partie de nos objectifs également ce
projet va agir comme une locomotive de
développement économique
ici à montréal et donc pour le québec
est également et finalement mais c'est
très important
on a toute la question de notre rôle est
de répondre aux besoins de nos clients
autrement dit
besoin comment ça se passe vous dire
qu'il ya eu du progrès depuis qu'on a
fendu sur mon passage voir la vidéo du
passé puisqu'on est annoncée une couple
de mois
du côté des responsables qu'ils aient
augmenté le nombre de migrants métro et
si vous vous souvenez bien on importait
beaucoup d'espoir là dessus il ya encore
des gens ici qui prennent le métro et le
mieux ce matin on va faire venir
marie-claude au microphone qui notre
nouvelle webmestre ici à radio-canada et
nationale elle fait de l'observation et
d'oxford pour ainsi si on se conduit
bien je devrais sont là faut pas trop
mais je vais demander est-ce que vous
avez mais choisel ajoutée par rapport à
sa gauche par le transport en commun
j'ai la chance d'être là où je suis très
vite servi comme une audi nettoyage en
pause 5,6 haute de ce qui passe devant
chez moi tous les matins et puis
j'arrive au à la station j'habitais mois
dans un pays qui fait juste à côté du
métro
je peux témoigner beaucoup beaucoup de
plus c'est une qualité incroyable quand
on passe qui sont dans ce trafic et
pouvant atteindre ces gens qui savent
pas conduire au quotidien et qui sont
tombés parce qu'on voit ça régulièrement
des gens qui disent
en autobus trois printemps droit d'un
temps plus tard 10 mai 10 idées et vous
le recommande recommandé aux gens de moi
alors on est cette fois ci on est
complètement un classique c'est très
lent
c'est un cauchemar en fait de se rendre
au centre-ville à part si vous demeurez
tout près de la station de train tout le
monde parle du train de banlieue qui est
extraordinaire c'est vrai mais demeurer
à 5 minutes sinon c'est il faut prendre
un autobus bon gars alors peut-être que
c'est pour ça que j'apprécie aujourd'hui
tellement le service que j'étudie au
point de vue c'est bien aller où vous
vous levez la main vous avez pas besoin
de nous inviter dans la désormais auprès
des fonds cauchemar si tu veux venir est
vraiment celle ci vous aussi tu veux
prendre l'autobus
il faut vraiment avoir de la patience
parce que c'est long c'est vrai j'ai
c'est long donc moi je prends les très
bien que le métro en fait est là mais
les matins je marche mais prêt est très
aimé trop ému ce commentaire je marche 7
8 minutes de la station comme on dit au
québec et sonneurs oui vous prenez le
métro des fois d'être buchou je conduis
pas en fait c'est un conditionnement je
prends l'autobus tous les jours ça va
bien un jour oui ça va bien comme marie
claude a dit je trouve que les
chauffeurs normalement ils sont très
gentils peut-être moins gentil que les
chauffeurs de longueuil parce que j'ai
pris l'autobus à londres et moi aussi
j'ai été impressionné oui oui j'ai été
impressionné mais sauf que oui ici pour
mon trajet ça va très bien je pense que
cette fois ci c'est plus ponctuelles ce
sera encore mieux mais ça il faut dire
qu'en hiver même la ville n'y peut rien
avec la tempête et jetons que je
reproche pas c'est vrai que c'est un
défi au niveau logistique à marie en
sorte votre tour non c'était une bonne
chose a dit
notons mais non mais non justement
j'étais en auto et je suis retourné en
métro et en autobus parce que j'habite
dans un coin est enclavée dans ce cas là
c'est verdun l'arrondissement de
montréal qui n'est pas très loin mais on
refait le pont champlain dont il ya des
travaux là on refait l'échangeur turcot
il ya des travaux là on refait je sais
plus quoi encore dont je ne peux plus
sortir de chez moi en voiture est
possible en tout cas compliqué lance ils
devraient me prendre quinze minutes me
prend maintenant une heure en voiture
vient donc je ne prends plus le la
voiture mais je prends le métro et
l'autobus le métro ça va super bien ils
ont ajouté des lignes et où l'autobus et
bah écoutez ça m'arrive des fois de
rentrer chez moi à pied parce que
j'attends l'autobus puis c'est quand
même une demi heure 40 minutes de marche
et j'ai le temps de rentrer chez moi à
pied la ligne est pas très bien
desservie alors on devrait donc jusqu'à
la fin on attend on a quatre 23 en
faveur légèrement sinon ça va ça va radi
vous venu en auto oui je viens en
hauteur en plus mais j'habite au
centre-ville donc ce qu'est à voir la
chose un peu ridicule léger mais il faut
dire ça mais il faut dire que j'ai pris
le métro points et le bus pendant au
moins dix ans avant de passer en voiture
et je compare souvent le transport en
commun à montréal autres transports en
commun que j'ai connus qui est celui de
rome en italie et je trouve que quand
même on est très bien servi rapport à
l'italie a oui c'est impressionnant est
d'ailleurs une des choses qui
impressionne souvent les étudiants
étrangers lorsqu'on arrive au québec ou
à montréal en particulier c'est la
politesse donc des effectivement des
chauffeurs la politesse aussi d'aider
des passagers enfin il le fait que tout
le monde soit un fils l'un après l'autre
qu'on attende qu'on paye bien à tiquer
qu'on n'essaie pas de faire de fraude
mais ces cultures à atteindre la finale
cédant doublions en italie c'est
vraiment le plus que le meilleur gagne
c'est un jeu de coudes des ingrédients
mais oui les femmes enceintes et comme
tout le monde je rentre donc on paye pas
le ticket donc il ya vraiment une
culture de de ne pas bien faire aussi
car il rentre messier peut-être avec la
difficulté à marcher femmes enceintes et
tout le monde doit s'élever à la j'ai
déjà eu aussi une discussion avec un
monsieur qui se fait s'est il fait
celles endormi il y avait ma dame dans
le train puis voulait pas laisser son
simple à la puis j'ai commencé à
monsieur où dormait oui madame qui
veulent dormir ailleurs à ce que c'est
ah je voulais pas mais je suis tombé et
je me souviens plus de quel pays d'asie
sais mais je vais essayer de retrouver
pendant une petite pause peut-être mais
une innovation extraordinaire que j'ai
vu c'est un petit en fait ils donnent un
petit une petite carte spéciale aux
femmes enceintes et à la gare dans leur
sac à main et lorsqu'elle rentre dans
une rame de métro est le signal il ya
une alerte lumineuse grandi qu'une femme
enceinte et au monde
elle ne s'étend que lorsqu elle s'assoit
et j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire parce
qu'effectivement il ya souvent des gens
qui vont faire semblant de ne pas voir
qu'il ya une femme enceinte qu'une
personne n'a personne âgée une personne
âgée de la mobilité réduite tout
simplement
et j'ai trouvé que c'était une
innovation vraiment ça se peut mais il
faut vraiment que vérifier je me
souviens plus c'était vraiment une
challenge des choses et ça c'est
vraiment très très bien pas dire des
choses ridicules qui se passe aussi au
métro il ya déjà il monte déjà en faire
de m'asseoir à leur écoute et on a des
salutations et c'est ça je vais vous
demander
oui on ahmadinjedad descendent luis
argentine c'est la ville où j'ai vient
alors dit bonjour lady en espagnol mais
dit bonjour je continue à vous voir
comme toujours et mazuch au loup au mot
intéressant des sénégalais matin
compatriotes
malik amer match les cowboys stadium
idy qui nous entend mais la partie de
l'année 1984 les fidèles musique et
c'est très physique
le sort des anglais qui nous écoutent
maintenant une main d'applaudissements à
ce qui nous renvoie la balle là pour
vous vous êtes là pour nous ça nous
encourage nom de l'énergie on glisse
vers la sortie malheureusement il y aura
pas de pause on glisse vers la sortie
avec ses commentaires par rapport à
notre question tam-tam écoute cette
semaine on termine donc avec ce qu'on a
le meilleur ce que les auditeurs nous
ont dit au sujet du transport
comment se portent vos transports chez
vous bon le commentaire de pascal et
band qui est un ancien collègue de radio
canada international
il ya une vingtaine d'années qui habite
aujourd'hui je pense à québec une ville
merveilleuse qu'est ce qu'il dit au
sujet du transport en commun
il dit je vis dans la capitale nationale
du québec où le transport en commun est
encore un vif sujet de débat sur lequel
le gouvernement municipal est sur nos
positions sont en désaccord beaucoup de
gens y sont réfractaires l'autobus est
le seul moyen de transport en commun et
faire offert à québec donc il n'ya pas
de bennoo je l'utilisais à l'occasion
pour de grandes distances mais lui
préfère la marche
personnellement je suis en vie je suis
en faveur d'un développement plus
audacieux et volontaire le tramway qui
fait toute la différence dans les villes
européennes comparables m'apparaît
depuis toujours comme la solution la
plus efficace performante et la plus
adaptée à notre territoire et à ses
conditions hivernales mais au sujet du
tram en a ajouté un article cette
semaine dans ce qu'on a créé au niveau
dudit projet tramway à montréal à québec
ce qui se passe à ton tour portage
complet sur représentés sont amenés à
cette émission il ya autre chose qui
ajoute mais le tramway me sens également
être l'auteur ici pour le développement
économique et touristique de l'ensemble
des arrondissements expliqué pour
l'instant soit ignorée par un visiteur
usines du québec a déjà mis son tramway
vers les années 1980 elle marie vont un
terminal avec votre soeur se trouve
france
il s'agit de qui exactement françoise
depardieu
une petite petite petite cousine alors
qu'ils me dit bonjour les amis je dois
vous dire qu'ici toulouse
moi je fais du centre de tous et le sud
à toulouse où nous avons habité toute
notre vie mon mari et moi nous n'aurions
vraiment pas besoin d'une auto pour
réaliser tous nos projets quotidien si
ce n'était de notre commerce
une petit boulanger et de fromage nous
n'utilisons notre véhicule cas pour
notre commerce ou pour aller voir les
oncles les tantes ce n'est pas commode
de transporter de la famille et du sucre
dans un top 12 en travers des jambes
d'étrangers pas toujours bien le corps
mutilé tanzanie lee a heureusement la
mobylette de notre fils qui nous a fait
faire des paniers en regard des
transports publics le problème n'a
jamais été le coup ou la fréquence de
mai les odeurs quoi à dire vrai surtout
par temps chaud
c'est une autre raison de fermer
boutique en nous et de prendre la poudre
d'escampette sans blague
il ya beaucoup de gens qui soit se
lavent une fois par semaine ou qu'ils
n'utilisent pas de billy bonnes senteurs
et de son agresseur de bus ou de car je
ne voudrais pas loin j'ai une amie qui
habite à paris
en été elle se plaint très souvent que
ça donc je pense que mes avants de
témoignages est-ce que je peux ajouter
un commentaire
le pain alors oui peut-être ne pas se
laver une fois par semaine mais les gens
qui se parfume à outrance c'est aussi
terrigènes moi j'avoue que j'ai une
intolérance pour les parfums trop fort
et déchets failli m'évanouir déjà dans
le métro collées sur des gens qui
s'entête gt ou passer les odeurs de par
femme elena sueur ça c'est difficile ce
que je me dise il vit à tête un autre
choix qu'on aurait pu faire ici
quelque chose qui manque et puis encore
avec un il apporte sa au travail je vous
fais pas de dessin je veux pas dénoncé
personne
il n'y a pas de coupable d en faire des
choses voilà le monde est parfait merci
infiniment cette semaine d'être venu
jouer le jeu à l'émission puis radis bay
on espère vous retrouver la semaine
prochaine et avec grand plaisir
et puis arrive on soit tant que tout va
bien se porter dans votre secteur dans
votre département et que oui oui oui
alors je vous reparlerai de ses
professeurs africains qui travailla
manouane des sénégalais entre autres par
tous les sénégalais des maghrébins dont
tunisiens marocains algériens il ya des
angolais il ya des congolais écoutez
l'afrique est un man wan et je vous en
reparle la semaine prochaine comme l'a
été toute une communauté
voilà et puis oui merci beaucoup d'être
venu cette semaine lé de la section
chinoise de radio-canada et ambitieux
nal merci à vous leonardo sans lequel
les mauvaises réponses
on en aurait pas merci pour le soutien
technique infinie que nous avait offert
cette semaine ici stéphane parent à la
semaine prochaine